what a wonderful day we have today and
what a wonderful time it is to write a
path tracer so why don't we get started
what we are gonna be looking at is a
program called small paint which is a
small path tracer in effectively 250
lines of code and it contains everything
that we have learned during this course
we're gonna be able to compute soft
shadows anti-aliasing Monte Carlo
integration and even quasi Monte Carlo
sampling which basically means low
discrepancy sampling this version of the
program is going to be able to compute
refractions color bleeding and caustics
and in the end the binary you can power
from the code can be compressed into
less than 4 kilobytes this is how the
end result looks like it has a beautiful
painterly look which actually comes from
a bug and you can also see that the
light source up there the whitish
looking sphere is you could say
perfectly anti aliased in order to
achieve this with a recursive ray tracer
and no global illumination algorithm you
would need to compute the very same
image on a much larger resolution and
then scale it down to a smaller image
like this and this anti aliasing effect
you get for free if you compute monte
carlo path tracing so the question is
how is this exactly done and now is the
best time to put everything into use
that we have learned so far so let's get
started we have a completely standard
vector class it is a three dimensional
vector it has its own constructor the
classical operators that you would
expect and we also have a dot product
for the vector and a cross product for
the vector it is also obviously possible
to compute the length of this vector so
nothing too exciting or important here
but we definitely need to build on a
solid vector class now the
representation of array array has an
origin and the direction and if
you take a close look at the constructor
you can see that when you initialize
array with a direction then this
direction is normed and the reason is
that when we compute the dot products
between these vectors most of these
information needs to be directional
information so we are not interested in
the magnitude of the vector only
interested in the direction of the
vector a good way to get rid of problems
where you would initialize your array
with directions that are not vectors of
unit length but you can do is to
normalize this input in the constructor
so you will never have headaches about
incorrect results where you have no idea
what is really happening what is the
representation of an object well an
object has a color this is denoted by CL
this is actually very sloppy notation
and this you can imagine as albedo but
it is not a double so it's not a number
it is actually a vector and the reason
for this is the fact that we need to
define the albedo's how much light in
different wavelengths is being reflected
and how much is being absorbed by the
given object now objects may also have a
mission if they have some nonzero
emission then their light sources and by
type we have an integer that would
specify what kind of brdf we have it is
also important to have an intersection
routine and some other function that can
compute the normal of the object now
these are of course virtual functions we
don't define them or an abstract object
but they would have to be implemented in
other classes that inherit from the
object let's take a look at a sphere so
a sphere has the C and our C is the
center of the objects and R is the
radius the constructor is trivial we
have the intersection function now if
you hopefully remember all three of the
elements of the quadratic function that
we need to solve but if you take a good
look then you will see that a is missing
from here and the question is why is
that the answer is we are multiplying D
with D the direct
vector of array with itself and if it's
a vector that is norm so it is of length
1 then this a will always be 1 after
that we can deal with the discriminant
the discriminant is normally not b
squared minus 4ac remember a is 1 here
so it's omitted but it is behind a
square root and this square root is
completely omitted here which looks like
a mistake
but it is not it is essentially an
optimization step because you will see
that we are testing the discriminant if
it's less than 0 if it's less than 0
then we don't need to deal with this
equation because the solutions for the
quadratic equation are going to exist in
the plane of complex numbers and that's
not a valid T it's not a valid distance
where we would intersect a sphere if
this is not happening then we can
compute the square root for the
discriminant Y after that because if the
discriminant is bigger than 0 then the
square root is not going to make a
difference
so what we can essentially do is to
postpone the square root calculation
after the test
note that square roots are really really
expensive so we can save up lots of
computational time if you omit this
calculation there is a really nice
square root hack in the source code of
quake 3 which is by the way open source
take a look at how people are trying to
hack together functions in order to work
better and faster than they should
because square roots are super expensive
and there are some really interesting
hacks in order to speed them up we have
the plus and minus term and the division
PI to a is again postponed and that's
also another interesting question why is
this postponed so you can see that the
soul 2 is divided by 2 and the soul 1 is
also divided by 2 but only after the
test so it is possible that if we have
the solution 2 if it is bigger than
Epsilon then we have the first
expression after the question mark but
if it's not then
we are looking for the second expression
after it which is another test and if
the answer is no for that as well then
we are going to return 0 this would mean
that we don't have any hits or the hits
are behind us and we are not interested
in intersections that are behind our
array there is a possibility that we
encountered this and in this case I
don't want to waste my time by dividing
these solutions by 2 because I'm not
going to use them why am i splitting
hairs here that's an important question
why do we need to optimize so much
because if you grab a profiler a program
that is able to show you in what
functions are you spending most of your
time in then this profiler would show
you that more than 90% of the execution
time is spent in the intersection
routines so you have to have a really
well optimized intersection routine some
programs have replaced these expressions
with assembly in order to speed it up
even more so how do we compute the
normal of a sphere well very simple what
we have here is P minus C now what does
it mean so if I have a minus B then this
means a vector that points from B to a
so what this would mean look at the
figure here if I would have a circle
then this would mean that from the
center it is pointing towards the given
points of the sphere now this is also
divided by or because you could imagine
you have a sphere that is not of unit
radius and if it's not of unit radius
then this normal vector would have a
length you could compute a normalization
we have a normalized function in our
vector implementation but it also has a
square root so it would be much better
to have something that's faster well if
you just divide by the radius of the
sphere then you would immediately get a
vector of unit length so in the end we
can get the correct result by just
simply dividing by our excellent now we
have a perspective camera here hopefully
you remember from the first lecture we
are basically just copy pasting this
expression here we have derived them
rigorously and analyzed how this exactly
works
simple intuition basically what we are
doing we have as an input and X and the
y basically this means give me a pixel
with this displacement and what it would
give you back is the world space
coordinates of these pixels uniform
sampling of a hemisphere
what is this for if we are encountering
a diffuse object what we would like to
do is to send array out on the
hemisphere of this object this we would
need to uniform this sample this means
that the diffuse brdf is one over pi or
ro over pi if you take into
consideration the albedo s-- and you
need transforms in order to do it there
is a reading behind this link how it
works exactly is drawing uniform samples
on a plane which is simple and then we
are projecting it on the hemisphere
that's basically all there is what about
the trace function as you can see here
in the first line this code says that
there is a maximum depth now clamping
after a maximum depth value is not
really optimal because whatever number
you put in there the higher order
bounces are going to be completely
omitted now the real solution would be
russian roulette' past termination which
we fortunately also have after depth of
an arbitrary number like 5 you start the
Russian Roulette routine which basically
says there is a probability for stopping
the light path right there and we
generate a random number and compare to
this probability if we don't hit this
probability then we will continue our
path but we will multiply the output and
the contribution of this light path by
this given number that we have specified
in one of the previous lectures so this
was implemented by christian maja check
and kind thanks
and you can see that later we are going
to use this RR factor in order to
multiply the contribution over a later
now what about the intersection routine
this is definitely not the best way to
do it but it's sure as hell the easiest
way to do it we specify this T which is
going to be the intersection distance
how far we are from the start of the
array and how far is this intersection
exactly I D is basically which object
did we hit and then we iterate through
all of the objects in the scene and what
we are interested in is calling the
intersection routine this will return a
T how far is the intersection and what I
am interested in an intersection that is
the smallest number this means the
closest intersection and also something
that is larger than Epsilon because if I
would tolerate zero then this would mean
that self intersections are accepted
therefore every single object that I am
on is going to be the first intersection
I'm not interested in this I know where
I am I just want to know where I am
continuing my path if there is no
intersection then we return there is
zero contribution where is the
intersection in world space we denote
this by HPU this means hit point and
where we have started array we traveled
along the direction of the Ray with this
T amount where the intersection is so
this is where we ended up and the origin
of the new ray is going to be this hit
point what is the normal going to be
well we just grabbed the object that we
intersected and we are taking the normal
with the given function what is the
return radiance we simply add the
emission term this is the emission term
on all three wavelengths there is a
magic multiplier disregard that and then
we continue evaluating the second part
of the rendering equation the first part
is the emission and the second is the
reflected amount of light let's continue
with the inside of the trace function if
we hit an object with the type of one
then this is a diffuse brdf the next
function
compute the next random number for the
low discrepancy halt on sampler and the
Direction is going to be a random sample
in the hemisphere a completely uniform
random sample in the hemisphere of this
object what we have here is this M plus
the hemisphere function this is
intuition this is not exactly what is
happening I've just shortened the code
slightly in order to simplify what is
going on here the code that you will
download will have the real deal in
there now then we compute the cosine
term very straightforward and on the TMP
we are going to instantiate a new vector
and this is going to hold the recursion
so the subsequent samples that we shoot
out from the hemisphere are going to be
added and added to this TMP now is the
time for recursion we passed array and
the scene to the trace function the
array is actually not the current one is
the new one so basically we set up the
new hit point and a new direction of the
array and this is what we are going to
pass to the trace function we increment
the depth variable because we have
computed the bounds the TMP is going to
be a variable where we gather all these
radians and we put every other parameter
that is needed to compute one more
bounds now the color is going to contain
the cosine term and all this radiance
that is collected from the recursion and
we multiply it with this CL that XYZ
which is basically the brdf so this is
the right side of the rendering equation
for the diffuse brdf this is multiplied
by 0.1 this is just a magic constant now
what about a specular brdf what if we
hit a mirror well very simple we compute
the perfect reflection direction you can
see the rate dot d and we again set up
this variable to collect the radiance in
there and we are not doing anything we
are just going to add the radiance as we
get reflected off of this mirror then we
are going to compute subsequent bounces
and this is going to be stored on this
TMP so this is what we're going to add
to this radiance
what about a refractive material well we
have every bit of knowledge that we need
for this because essentially this is the
vector version of Snell's law what does
it mean well the original Snell's law
that we have computed is in 1d so it
only gives you one angle but if you are
in 3d you are interested in angles in
two different dimensions this is nothing
but the extension of the very same law
into higher dimension now where is this
implemented exactly you can see the
cosine of theta to note that N 1 and n 2
is considered differently because one of
these media is always going to be air
therefore one of the indices of
refraction is always going to be 1 the
rest is just copy-paste and again you
can see that the square root is missing
and we are going to postpone this after
the test of cosine T 2 because if it is
actually not larger than 0 then we are
not going to need this variable at all
therefore we can postpone this after the
test again what about the direction of
the outgoing ray well this is just
copy-paste from the formula that we have
derived before so simple as that
obviously we again need the recursion
because if we go inside a glass sphere
then we are going to compute the
refraction so we are going to be inside
of the sphere what does it mean one that
we have to invert the normal because we
are inside so the normals are flipped
and again we need to compute the trace
function which is the recursion so we
are also interested in the higher order
bounces onwards to friends law what is
the probability of reflection and
refraction when rays are bouncing off in
different directions in different angles
off of refractive surfaces implemented
by Christian Hafner so a big thanks for
him it is very simple you can see that
it is exactly the same as what we have
learned in mathematics so this is the R
0 term this is the probably
of reflection in normal incidents and we
are interested in the square of that and
note that you don't see the n1 and n2
this is because one of them is always
going to be air or vacuum so it is going
to have the index of refraction of one
now what about the final probability of
reflection it is also coming from the
formula we have every bit of information
we need so we just put in there this
term with the cosine attenuation how
does the main function look like well we
have some wizardry with C++ 11 lambda
functions but basically this is just a
shortcut in order to be able to add the
new sphere or a new plane to the scene
in one line of code Spears are given by
their radius position color by color we
obviously mean abidos emission and type
type means what kind of brdf we have a
diffuse a specular or a refractive brdf
now for planes we have position normal
color emission and obviously type so
what kind of material we have so using
just one line of code you can add a new
object and specify everything every
information that you would need to it
now we also add the light source and we
specify the index of refraction for the
refractive brdf and we also specify how
many samples per pixel would be like to
compute onwards to the main loop we have
two four loops that iterate through the
width and the height of the image plane
now vector C is color it's again very
sloppy what it means is actually the
radiance that we compute we instantiate
array what is going to be the origin of
the array this is going to be zero zero
zero so this is where the camera is
placed what is going to be the direction
of the ray while we connect this ray to
the camera plane and we specify which
pixel we are computing with I and J and
then we add this weird random number to
it now what this means is actually
filtering in recursive ray tracing what
you would do is you would own
Sam DeRay through the midpoint of a
pixel and that's it you would compute
one sample per pixel in Monte Carlo path
tracing your computing many samples per
pixel and they don't have to go through
the midpoint of the pixel you would
sample the area of the pixel and this
gives you anti-aliasing effects for free
if you use it correctly what is going to
be the direction of the Ray pollicis
again the same a minus B the B is the
origin of the Ray and a is the camera
coordinate so what does it mean that it
is pointing from zero to the camera
plane and we normalize this expression
to have array of unit length now we
obviously call the trace function the
number of bounces is zero and we pass
every information that needs to be known
in order to compute these bounces so we
provide this initial ray and the scene
and everything else obviously we also
pass the C and this is going to collect
all the radians there is in the
subsequent bounces and then after this
recursion is done we deposit all this
energy all this radiance to the
individual pixels and then we divide by
the number of samples because if we
wouldn't do this then you remember the 1
over N multiplier everywhere in Monte
Carlo integration if you wouldn't do
this then the more samples you compute
the brighter image you would get and
this is obviously not what we are
looking for
at the very end we create a file this is
the ppm file format where you can easily
write all your contributions in there we
also start a stopwatch in order to
measure how long we have been tracing
all these race so very simple very
trivial and when we are done we close
the file it has the image in there and
we then write how long the rendering
algorithm has been running for and
basically that's it that's it this is
effectively 250 lines of code that can
compute indirect illumination caustics
and every global illumination effect and
it can compute images like this this is
one student submission from previous
years absolutely gorgeous this is the
fixed version of small paint where there
are no errors in the sampling another
one from the hakama this actually looks
like I don't know if you are into the
music band Boards of Canada but this
looks exactly like one of their album
covers love it
really cool and also sierpinski
triangles from Christi and Khosla you
can find the link for the code in there
and take a crack at it
just try it build different scenes try
to understand what is going on in there
try to mess the code up I wonder what
happens if I would not normalize this
vector play with it it's a really small
concise and really understandable part
tracer so take your time and play with
it it's lots of fun and you can create
lots of beautiful beautiful images with
global illumination thank you